مرحبًا ، اسمي إيلينا ، نحن حاليًا في
كييف أوكرانيا في حملة لجمع التبرعات للوشم
تسمى الوخز بالإبر حيث نقوم بعمل وشم
لجمع الأموال للجيش الأوكراني
حتى الآن ، فقد عقدنا 12 حدثًا
وجمعنا أكثر من نصف مليون من كليفينا
للمدافعين لدينا.  هذه الأحداث كل يوم
سبت وأخطط للقيام بها حتى
تنتهي الحرب أو طالما أنه
يجب القيام بها
قبل الحرب لم أكن حقًا في
السياسة ولم أعبر عن وجهة نظري السياسية
أو أي شيء من هذا
القبيل بالتأكيد  تغيرت بعد الغزو ،
استيقظت من انفجار
وكانت السماء بأكملها
تنفجر إنذارات السيارة الحمراء وأحب أن
العمل قد بدأ كما لو كان قد بدأ
أثناء حظر التجول ، يمكنك مغادرة
المنزل ،
لقد جلسنا هناك ونقوم بالوشم
وتناول الطعام كما هو الحال هناك  لم يكن هناك أي شيء آخر للقيام
بذلك ، نعم ، لقد حصلت على وشم واحد يقول
أعز شيء من هذا القبيل
وكرسته لأوكرانيا ،
لقد عدنا إلى هنا ووجدنا
موقعًا كان شريط صديقنا
قرر وضع كل هذا معًا
في البداية  الحبر كان مثل 10 ربما 15
رسامًا للوشم بقوا في
الكهف وأرادوا المساعدة بقدر ما فعلنا
[موسيقى] ،
اجتمعنا جميعًا وفوجئنا كثيرًا
بعدد الأشخاص الذين
حضروا وهم يحبونك
أفهم أن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
أغادر فيها منزلي منذ شهر
أجنبي
دي جي ،
نعم إنه أول وشم لي ، أنا قلق بعض الشيء
لأنني سأغادر البلاد يوم الخميس
لمدة شهرين على الأقل وأردت
أن أحصل على  شيء وطني
قبل أن أفعل ذلك ،
لذا أحصل على ترايدنت حتى أتمكن من
إبعاد الناس عن
النمط الأوكراني الذي تعرفه
سيارات الأجرة
[موسيقى]
مع